SPEAKER_00: Good morning Robert, thanks for bringing Linda with you today. I know estate planning can be a sensitive topic for couples.
SPEAKER_01: We're not getting any younger. We figured it's time to get serious about this.
SPEAKER_02: Especially with the new grandkid coming. We want to make sure everyone's taken care of.
SPEAKER_00: Congratulations on the grandchild! That's often what motivates people to, uh, finally tackle estate planning.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, when you realize there's a whole new generation depending on you, it puts things in perspective.
SPEAKER_00: Absolutely. So let's start with the basics. Do you currently have wills or any estate documents?
SPEAKER_02: We have wills from about ten years ago, but they're probably outdated. A lot has changed since then.
SPEAKER_00: That's common. What kind of changes are we talking about?
SPEAKER_01: Our net worth has grown significantly. We sold our business three years ago for approximately... um... two point five million.
SPEAKER_00: Congratulations. So you're potentially looking at federal estate tax issues now?
SPEAKER_02: That's what we're worried about. We don't really understand how it all works.
SPEAKER_00: No worries, that's what I'm here for. The federal exemption is twelve point nine two million per person this year.
SPEAKER_01: So twenty-five point eight four million for a married couple?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly, if you plan properly. But here's the catch - those limits are set to drop significantly after twenty twenty-five.
SPEAKER_02: Drop to what?
SPEAKER_00: Probably around six to seven million per person, adjusted for inflation. The Tax Cuts and Jobs Act provisions expire.
SPEAKER_01: So we could go from being under the limit to being over it, just like that?
SPEAKER_00: Potentially, yes. What's your total net worth currently, if you don't mind me asking?
SPEAKER_02: Between the sale proceeds, our retirement accounts, and real estate, probably around four point two million.
SPEAKER_00: So you're likely safe under current rules, but if the exemption drops and your assets continue growing, you could face significant tax liability.
SPEAKER_01: We could have a problem then. What's the tax rate on estates?
SPEAKER_00: Forty percent on amounts over the exemption. It's quite substantial.
SPEAKER_02: Forty percent? That's higher than our income tax rate!
SPEAKER_00: It is. The good news is there are strategies we can implement now while the exemptions are still high.
SPEAKER_01: Like what kind of strategies?
SPEAKER_00: Gifting is the most straightforward. You can each give eighteen thousand per recipient per year without using your lifetime exemption.
SPEAKER_02: So we could give thirty-six thousand to our daughter and her husband each year?
SPEAKER_00: Each year, yes. Plus another thirty-six thousand to each grandchild.
SPEAKER_01: So if we have two grandkids eventually, that's, what, a hundred and eight thousand annually?
SPEAKER_00: Right. And it removes that money from your taxable estate, plus any future growth.
SPEAKER_02: But what if we need that money for our own retirement? That's my main concern.
SPEAKER_00: That's the key question. You never want to compromise your own financial security.
SPEAKER_01: We've run the numbers. We think we can live comfortably on about two hundred thousand annually.
SPEAKER_00: And your assets should generate that through a combination of investment returns and withdrawals?
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, we're thinking a four percent withdrawal rate. That's about a hundred sixty thousand, plus Social Security benefits.
SPEAKER_00: And what will your combined Social Security benefits be?
SPEAKER_01: About sixty thousand annually once we both file at full retirement age.
SPEAKER_00: So you'd have a buffer there. That's good. Makes gifting more feasible.
SPEAKER_02: What about bigger gifts? Can we give more than the annual limit?
SPEAKER_00: You can, but it uses up your lifetime exemption. Though with the current high limits, that might actually make sense.
SPEAKER_01: How much could we give without triggering taxes?
SPEAKER_00: Well, you could each gift up to twelve point nine two million over your lifetime without estate tax.
SPEAKER_02: So we could give away a million dollars now and still be under the limit?
SPEAKER_00: Correct. And if the exemption drops in twenty twenty-six, you'll have locked in the higher limit, which is smart.
SPEAKER_01: That's like grandfathering in the current rules?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. It's called 'use it or lose it' planning. Once the exemption drops, you can't go back.
SPEAKER_02: But giving away a million dollars seems quite daunting to us.
SPEAKER_00: Understandable. We could start smaller and build up to it. Maybe two hundred thousand this year.
SPEAKER_01: And put it in trust for the grandkids?
SPEAKER_00: That's one option. A five twenty-nine education savings plan is another.
SPEAKER_02: What's the advantage of a trust versus five twenty-nine?
SPEAKER_00: Trusts offer more control and flexibility. Five twenty-nines are simpler but they're limited to education expenses.
SPEAKER_01: Can you do a lump sum contribution to a five twenty-nine?
SPEAKER_00: Yes, you can contribute up to ninety thousand at once by using five years' worth of annual exclusions.
SPEAKER_02: So a hundred eighty thousand for both of us?
SPEAKER_00: Per beneficiary, yes. So if you have two grandkids, that's three hundred sixty thousand total.
SPEAKER_01: And it grows tax-free if used for education?
SPEAKER_00: Right. Plus you maintain some control - you can change beneficiaries if needed.
SPEAKER_02: What happens if the kids don't go to college?
SPEAKER_00: You can withdraw the money, but you'll pay taxes plus a ten percent penalty on the gains.
SPEAKER_01: Or transfer it to another family member?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Nieces, nephews, even yourself for continuing education.
SPEAKER_02: That seems pretty flexible.
SPEAKER_00: It is. Now, let's talk about your retirement accounts. How much do you have in IRAs and four-oh-one-ks?
SPEAKER_01: About one point eight million combined. Mostly traditional accounts.
SPEAKER_00: Those will be subject to required minimum distributions starting at seventy-three.
SPEAKER_02: Which means more taxable income for us, right?
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. And your heirs will have to withdraw everything within ten years now.
SPEAKER_01: That could push them into higher tax brackets?
SPEAKER_00: Very likely. Might be worth considering some Roth conversions now while you're in lower tax brackets.
SPEAKER_02: We're essentially retired, so our income is pretty low.
SPEAKER_00: Perfect time for conversions. You could convert up to the top of the twelve percent bracket quite cost-effectively.
SPEAKER_01: How much is that?
SPEAKER_00: For married filing jointly, about eighty-three thousand in taxable income.
SPEAKER_02: So we could convert maybe sixty thousand per year?
SPEAKER_00: Depends on your other income, but that's in the ballpark. Over ten years, that's six hundred thousand.
SPEAKER_01: And our kids inherit it tax-free?
SPEAKER_00: Right. Plus it reduces the size of your traditional IRA, which could help with estate taxes later.
SPEAKER_02: This is getting complicated. Should we really be working with an estate attorney?
SPEAKER_00: Absolutely. I can help with the financial planning, but you'll need legal documents.
SPEAKER_01: What kind of documents are we talking about?
SPEAKER_00: Updated wills, probably a revocable living trust, powers of attorney, healthcare directives.
SPEAKER_02: What's the advantage of a trust over just having wills?
SPEAKER_00: Trusts avoid probate, provide more privacy, and can be more efficient for managing assets.
SPEAKER_01: Is probate really that bad?
SPEAKER_00: Depends on the state. Some states have quick and inexpensive probate, while others can take years and cost tens of thousands of dollars.
SPEAKER_02: We're in California. I've heard probate here is quite expensive.
SPEAKER_00: It can be. Statutory fees alone could be fifty thousand or more on a four million dollar estate.
SPEAKER_01: Fifty thousand? That's a significant amount to lose to fees.
SPEAKER_00: Plus it's all public record. Anyone can see what you owned and who inherited what.
SPEAKER_02: We definitely value our privacy.
SPEAKER_00: Then a trust makes sense. You can transfer assets now and avoid the whole probate process.
SPEAKER_01: Do we lose control of our assets?
SPEAKER_00: Not with a revocable trust. You're the trustees, so you maintain complete control while you're both alive.
SPEAKER_02: And then what happens when we're both gone?
SPEAKER_00: Your successor trustee distributes assets according to your instructions. Could be immediate or over time.
SPEAKER_01: We're worried about our daughter getting everything at once. That concerns us.
SPEAKER_00: Understandable. You could structure it to distribute in stages - like one-third at twenty-five, one-third at thirty, one-third at thirty-five.
SPEAKER_02: Or tie it to milestones like graduating college or getting married?
SPEAKER_00: You can do that, though some attorneys actually discourage tying distributions to personal choices.
SPEAKER_01: Why's that?
SPEAKER_00: It can create perverse incentives. What if she chooses not to marry or pursues a different path than college?
SPEAKER_02: Good point. Age-based distributions might be simpler.
SPEAKER_00: They are. Plus the trustee can always make discretionary distributions for health, education, or emergencies.
SPEAKER_01: Who should be the successor trustee?
SPEAKER_00: Often a family member, but you could also use a corporate trustee or a combination.
SPEAKER_02: What are the pros and cons?
SPEAKER_00: Family trustees are free but may lack expertise. Corporate trustees are professional but charge fees.
SPEAKER_01: How much do corporate trustees typically charge?
SPEAKER_00: Usually around one percent of assets annually. So on four million, that's about forty thousand per year.
SPEAKER_02: That seems like a lot.
SPEAKER_00: It is, but they handle all the administrative work, tax filings, investment management.
SPEAKER_01: Maybe we start with family and switch to corporate if needed?
SPEAKER_00: That's possible. You can build successor provisions into the trust document.
SPEAKER_02: What about life insurance? Do we need that?
SPEAKER_00: Depends. If you have estate tax exposure, life insurance can provide liquidity to pay taxes.
SPEAKER_01: We used to have life insurance when we had the business, but we let it lapse.
SPEAKER_00: At your age, new policies will be expensive and might not be cost-effective.
SPEAKER_02: What if we end up with estate tax liability?
SPEAKER_00: Your executor could sell assets to pay the taxes. Not ideal, but workable.
SPEAKER_01: Better than paying expensive insurance premiums for twenty years?
SPEAKER_00: Probably. Though we could run some scenarios to see if it ever makes sense.
SPEAKER_02: This has been very informative.
SPEAKER_00: Good. Estate planning isn't just about taxes - it's about making sure your wishes are carried out.
SPEAKER_01: And protecting our family.
SPEAKER_00: Exactly. Let me give you a referral to an estate attorney who specializes in situations like yours.
SPEAKER_02: That would be great. What should we do in the meantime?
SPEAKER_00: Start thinking about your goals. How much do you want to leave to family versus charity?
SPEAKER_01: We'd like to leave enough so our kids can pursue their dreams, but not so much they lose motivation.
SPEAKER_00: That's a common goal. Warren Buffett calls it "enough money to do anything, but not enough to do nothing."
SPEAKER_02: That's a good way to put it.
SPEAKER_00: Alright, let me get you that attorney referral, and we can schedule a follow-up after you've met with them.
SPEAKER_01: Sounds perfect. Thanks for helping us think through all this.
SPEAKER_00: My pleasure. Estate planning can seem overwhelming, but taking it step by step makes it more manageable.
SPEAKER_02: We feel much better having a roadmap.
SPEAKER_00: That's the goal. Peace of mind for you and security for your family.